I Calgary a secretary general of the
OECD we had a fascinating session on
measuring progress the so-called going
beyond GDP discussion and what was more
important is that we all see it as a
very powerful tool that we should
continue to develop in order to be able
to put together what people want and
what governments can offer and therefore
have a greater level of satisfaction
there was a discussion whether we're
talking about happiness or progress or
satisfaction is really not so important
because we would like to try to measure
happiness but we probably can't and
maybe a capturing a progress Kathleen
level of satisfaction is really more
what we want to do we've developed the
OECD a better life index and to answer
the question that we oppose each other
every day how's life and how to answer
the question how's life we've developed
as better life index which allows you to
do it for the country now for a group of
countries for the region but also allows
it to do it in for yourself for your
better life index and your level of
satisfaction at a personal level this
all should develop into better tools so
that the government's know better what
it is that people want and deliver
better quality services that deliver the
infrastructure deliver the water
delivered the electricity but also the
quality of life the well-being which is
more than just GDP